this is a poster presentation for a
project done in collaboration between
the gucci memorial institute for medical
research
and pine biotech my name is ilya brodsky
and i am working together with our team
at pine biotech dr mohit mazumdar and dr
harpreet or
as well as our collaborators at
university of ghana dr anita kansa
and dr benedict mensah our poster is on
plasmodium falciparum
apical membrane antigen robbery neck
protein 2 binding
which is a critical interaction for
plasmodium foscipromerozite invasion
of human host red blood cells several
proposed malaria vaccine candidates
designed to prevent such binding
and limit merozoite entry have been
studied with variable success
at in vitro and early clinical trial
stages
by performing haplotype network analysis
of genomic sequencing data from sites
with variable infection rates
comparing our data with malaria gen
repository from another region in ghana
and mapping of genomic variants onto the
protein structures
we arrive at preliminary conclusions
about local variation
and immunogenic epitope affecting
variants for consideration
in this poster we share preliminary
findings that suggest
that the genomic data can be used to
develop a local strategy for efficacious
vaccine design
against plasmodium falciparum blood
stage infection in ghana
and surrounding regions ma1 run 2
binding is a critical interaction for
p-falciparum
merizoit invasion of host red blood
cells which causes clinical
manifestation of malaria
several proposed malaria vaccine
candidates designed to prevent such
binding
and limit merozoite entry have been
studied with variable success
at in vitro and early clinical trial
stages
one key observation about vaccine
efficacy based on these proteins is the
genetic diversity
of ma1 in parasite populations
associated with disease burden
transmission rates and various
environmental factors
our team here analyzes ama1 genomic data
from the goron
cape coast in ghana the two towns are
240 kilometers apart
and represent parasite populations in
the forest and coastal savannah
ecological regions of ghana
with variable transmission rates in this
project we wanted to
understand how ama1 protein in these
populations differs from the 3d7 strain
of p falciparum
that is considered to be prevalent in
sub-saharan africa and was used for the
vaccine being considered
in this region two identify prevalent
snips
and specific mutation signatures for
each population
and compare those with data from other
regions in ghana
three see whether snips in
immunodominant domains are affected by
variable immune pressures
by exploring b-cell and t-cell epitopes
and four
ask the question about potential gene
flow between parasites in these two
towns
located in different ecological regions
our analysis workflow combines
processing of raw data
alignment of consensus sequences for the
reference 3d7 strain
haplotype analysis to determine
population structure and variability
followed by identification of haplotypes
specific for each population
and combinations of snips in haplotypes
that are also specific to these
populations
the analysis was conducted using new
data collected from the goron cape coast
in ghana during the peak malaria
transmission seasons
over a four year period 150 sequences
from the goro
and 181 from cape coast were obtained by
molecular inversion probe capture and
deep sequencing on the aluminum ic
platform
raw sequencing reads were aligned to the
p4 ciprim reference genomes trained 3d7
using mip wrangler and seek deep
downstream analysis of synonymous and
non-synonymous
variants was conducted using eugene r
scripts and the t by info platform
to determine genetic diversity within
and between both populations we
performed haplotype analysis based on
the full sequence of ama1
as well as a ma1 domain 1 where the
binding site with ron 2 is located
to calculate a haplotype distribution we
used pigas
and ape are packages haplotype networks
were generated using the templeton
crandall and sting tcs method
and filtering haplotypes for frequency
of occurrence
haplotypes were further analyzed for
specificity of mutations to each
location
and their impact on protein structure to
explore the immune pressures on
population structures at both locations
we explored genomic variation and
predicted b-cell and t-cell epitopes
b-cell epitopes were predicted using the
bepi pred 2.0 method
and tepee tool pipeline for
computational prediction of t-cell
epitope candidates
on the iedb analysis resource server the
predicted peptide structures were mapped
onto the ama1 protein structure
3zwz for downstream analysis
analysis of genomic variation in
collected samples reveals
that the ama-1 in cape coast and vigoro
have different intra-population
diversity and many nucleotide
differences from the 3d7 laboratory
strain being used as the dominant strain
in people's eprom population in
sub-saharan africa
to understand the impact of this
variation on protein-coding
immunodominant regions
we performed analysis of non-synonymous
mutations in a critical
functional domain that has the potential
impact on immune evasion
first we considered the full length of
ama1
overall we identified common variants in
102 positions
in the 1767 nucleotide
long ama1 gene which is about six
percent
we identified several positions with
higher frequency of variance including
physicians 116
523 845 876
988 and 995. next we compared prevalence
of combinations of mutations using
haplotype
analysis using the tcs method we
conducted haplotype analysis which
identified 193 total haplotypes
from 331 samples from the goro and cape
coast
haplotype 1 is identical to people 37
reference
haplotype 1 was found in only 6 of the
samples
2 in vigoro and 4 in cape coast that is
less than 2 percent of the full
population
mutations at 6 positions were found to
be common
among most of the haplotypes g116a
t523g t845a
g876a c988t995a
four mutations are more prevalent in
cape coast than vigoro
and one mutation is more prevalent in
decoro
than cape coast then we wanted to
understand differences between parasite
populations in these regions of variable
transmission
we found that seventy percent of the
haplotypes had significant variation
over 26 variants or more than one
percent
and thirty percent had minor variation
from the reference p-falciprom3d7 strain
which is between one and twenty-six
variants of these observed haplotypes 62
occurred at least twice
and were used to construct a network
which shows haplotype frequency
distribution and divergence into
specific groups
each haplotype corresponds to a sequence
which can be found in both population or
belong to a specific population only
most haplotypes are more prevalent in
cape coast
next we filtered 42 key haplotypes out
of a total of 193 haplotypes with
frequency
difference of at least two between both
populations
out of these 42 19 haplotypes are unique
for cape coast
15 unique for bagoro and seven and one
significantly more prevalent in cape
coast and vigorous respectively
constructed network shows no significant
separation between the two locations
with most prevalent haplotypes shared
between populations
the ama1 protein consists of three
domains
domains one and two are strongly
conserved across the
epic complex of phylum suggesting a
concerned function for these domains
whereas domain 3 is divergent on the
other hand
within the plasmodium species
polymorphisms are concentrated in domain
1 and to a lesser extent domain 2.
domain 1
contains a hydrophobic groove where
binding with ron 2 has to take place for
parasite invasion of red blood cells
previous literature reports that the
population structure of ama1
alleles is reflective of diversifying
selection under the pressure of the host
immune system
we analyze haplotype diversity by
considering only
ama1 domain 1 nucleotide positions 445
to 906
haplotype analysis yielded 93
hamplotypes
27 haplotypes that are specific to the
goro
30 specific to cape coast and 36 shared
by both populations
among the 27 haplotypes that are
reasonably different between
these populations in terms of frequency
difference
more than two between populations had
six haplotypes that are specific to cape
coast and
seven that are specific to the goro 14
haplotypes that were shared
had 10 that are more prevalent in cape
coast
with a difference of at least two and
four in the goro
for domain one haplotypes we observed
that mutations t523g
and g876a are present in all haplotypes
except haplotype 1 which is identical to
the reference
mutations at 6 positions g116a
t523g t845a
g876a c988t
t995a were found to be common among most
of the haplotypes
four mutations t566c a729t
c848t a163c
are more prevalent in cape coast than
vigoro and one mutation g106a
is more prevalent in vigoro than cape
coast
next we wanted to understand how ama1
residue conservation varies between
populations
we analyzed ama1 conservation using the
al2co method
in ucsf chimera by calculation of
positional conservation in a protein
sequence alignment
based on entropy this entropy based
conservation analysis revealed variable
positions specific to the goro with high
variability in vigoro
and conserved in cape coast for begoro
high variability positions can be seen
in red
these regions were more variable in cape
coast cape coast high variability
positions can be seen in blue
these regions were more variable in cape
coast
we then looked at where these positions
are located based on ma1 domain 1.
we found that region 5 a position 221 to
224
and 3 a positions 167 to 170
are more variable in the goro and
conserved in cape coast
these locations are within the
hydrophobic region of ama1 round 2
binding which is essential for merozoite
entry into the red blood cell and is a
target for many considered anti-malarial
drugs conversely region 4 a185 to 188
is more variable in cape coast while it
is conserved in degoro
this region is likely important for
binding as well since it is a part of
the loop covering the hydrophobic
binding region
next we assessed how the haplotype
variants in ama1
might reflect immune pressure specific
to each region
and how these variants might affect
b-cell and t-cell recognition
by mapping identified variants on
predicted t-cell and b-cell epitopes
six variants were identified to have an
effect on b-cell epitopes
of which two l-189p and
s-283-l were more prevalent in cape
coast affecting b-cell epitopes
two mutations were unique and more
specific to the cape coast population
others were common polymorphic sites
prevalent in haplotypes for both
populations
interestingly one of the longest b-cell
epitopes
aa163 to 212 was determined to be
significantly more variable in bogoro
and conserved than cape coast as
described previously
varian i-332n which is common in both
populations
is found in one of the predicted b-cell
epitopes with a blossom score
of -3 analysis of predicted t-cell
epitopes was filtered for score above
0.9
one variant found in the predicted
epitopes is y175d
which was common for both sites and is
likely to affect t cell recognition by
its impact on mhc class 1 molecule
binding specificity
y to d blossom 62 score of minus 3.
discussion using ama1 sequence data
generated from mip capture and targeted
deep sequencing of 181 and 150 clinical
parasite isolates
from cape coast in the coastal savannah
region
and begoro in the forest region of ghana
we observed extensive nucleotide
variation
in the ama 1 genomic sequences there
were 193 haplotypes of which 70 percent
had over 26 variants this high genetic
diversity is known to occur in high
transmission areas
where infected individuals usually
harbor more polyclonal infections
compared to those living in low
transmission areas
where infections are more often
monoclonal
we found that circulating ama1
haplotypes in the cape coast
population were more diverse in
distribution and uniqueness
in both the full gene and the
immunodominant domain one
despite this high level of genetic
diversity including
multiple non-synonymous nucleotide
substitutions
population structure shows that there is
a shared gene pool between the two sites
as indicated in previous studies the
human population is likely to facilitate
gene flow among people supreme parasites
despite the ecological and
epidemiological diversity between the
two sites the human movement factor is a
significant
consideration with implications for the
spread of any emerging vaccine resistant
parasite
of significance is the low frequency of
3d7
ama1 reference haplotype in the two
ghanian sites
with implications for vaccine efficacy
several amino acid changes in domain 1
occurred in predicted b-cell epitopes
and may affect both naturally acquired
and vaccine-induced ma1 immunity in
addition
t-cell epitope variant y-175d
circulating on both sides is likely to
affect mhc
class 1 binding specificity with
implications for long-term vaccine
efficacy
novel sites mapped on the
three-dimensional structure of
ama1 showed that these regions were
located at exposed protrusions and are
unique to the two ghanian sites
potentially these mutations could be
affecting the binding between the two
proteins in ghana
in contrast to literature findings that
common mutations like these
do not affect binding affinity this
could be due to the fact that the
overall pocket properties are not
changed and ron 2 also has variation to
adapt
to this new confirmation one limitation
to this observation is that we did not
sequence the wrong to gene
in the same sites we are planning
additional studies to explore the impact
of found mutations on potential binding
and restrictions to propose drug
candidates aimed at this hydrophobic
site
we believe that the results highlight
important considerations and may provide
significant value to the design of a
malaria vaccine
based on this antigen and offer insights
into the efficacy of ama1 vaccines in
ghana
further analysis on molecular dynamics
of the major circulating ama1 variants
and the wrong two variants in ghana
will shed more light on the effect of
the extensive genetic diversity
on the red blood cell parasite invasion
and vaccine efficacy for the formulation
of more effective vaccines importantly
our study also demonstrates the utility
of in-depth bioinformatic analysis for
practical public health concerns
in this region